Bladesmiths, welcome
to the forge.
And welcome to our legendary
bladesmithing competition
like none other
you've ever experienced.
Bladesmiths, here in the forge,
we draw our inspiration
from history
and history's legends
like King Arthur,
and his legendary
sword in the stone,
Excalibur.
Well, here in our first round
of competition today,
you guys will be
choosing your fate
by drawing your own swords
from this stone.
Etched on the side of each one
of these blades
is a particular
Damascus pattern
that you will have to execute
in your final blade
by the end of this round.
I'm gonna call you up
one at a time
in a random order.
And you'll draw your sword
from this stone.
Scott, you're up first.
Pick your poison, buddy.
[adventurous music playing]
It's not the one, huh?
Oh, there it is.
-What do you got there, Scott?
-100 layer Damascus.
Ooh, good luck
with that one, buddy.
All right, Jarrett,
choose your sword.
-What'd you pull?
-Ladder pattern Damascus.
Colton, come
and choose your sword.
All right, what'd
you pull, Colton?
[Colton] Twisted Damascus.
How am I supposed to get
a twisted Damascus blade
forged in three hours?
Your three hours starts now.
[Scott] I choose 16 layers
alternating of 1095
and 15N20.
My plan is to get
enough small pieces
that I can stack together
to form my 100 layers.
It's too frickin' big
for this forge.
This is easily the hardest thing
I've ever done.
[Wil] Colton's 18 years old.
He's been forging
since he was 10.
But here we have
a twist-pattern Damascus.
What are we talking about here
with this?
[Ben] What Colton's gonna
have to do is
forge-weld his layers together,
draw them out into a bar,
and physically twist the bar.
[Jarrett] I'm going to get
two billets forged out
so I have twice
as much material
to get those layers up
so you can see that pattern
and go from there.
[Wil] Colton, he's over there
on Big Blue
and his forge welds look great.
[Colton] My welds
are taking amazingly.
I'm not having
any problems at all.
It's miraculous.
-That stack is big and long.
-Yeah.
[Scott] I believe what's left
has a very good weld on it.
So I keep going.
I got the billet all drawn out.
I wanna get the layer count up.
So both of these are 16 layers,
so that would be,
what, 32 layers.
If the layers weren't there,
that pattern would
kind of be muddled, so...
I'm a little nervous
just because there's a big gap
in between these
two pieces of steel.
But I fluxed it pretty good,
so hopefully it'll stick.
[Colton] I'm feeling pretty good
right now.
I think I'm ready to twist.
Right now I still
have 16 layers.
[Wil] Scott still has
to do a restack.
Yeah. Hopefully
he's got that math right.
With seven layers of 16,
that'll give me over 100 layers.
[exclaims]
Man, that Colton,
he's doing a great job.
And that's the cool thing.
Colton is done.
All he has to do now
is make a knife.
This kid is smart.
[Colton] I got an hour left
to quench.
And might as well
just do it now.
Colton quenches.
I pulled it out of the oil
and it's perfectly straight.
Now I have plenty of time
to finish grinding the bevels.
And there he goes,
Jarrett's in the quench.
[Jarrett] Comes out
fairly straight.
It has a little bit of a, uh,
corkscrew to it,
but nothing I wouldn't
be able to grind out.
I get the blade roughly shaped.
I'm pleased with the pattern.
I am not pleased
with the handle.
I'm going to have to do
a lot of alterations to it
to make it work properly.
Scott just quenched his blade.
Whoa!
[Scott] Surprised
it's pretty straight.
But right now I've gotta
get the scale off
so I can dip it in acid
before the clock runs out.
Three, two, one!
Bladesmiths, shut down
your machines.
Drop your tools.
This first round
of Damascus competition
is over.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the stone chop.
In this test,
we're gonna test your edge
and your overall construction
of your blades
to see how they hold up.
I'll be smashing them
into these stones.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready?
[rock music playing]
Well, Colton...
First things first,
your blade held up really well.
There's evidence
of some serious scratching
from the stone,
but we're bashing
a knife into a rock,
so I expect
some kind of abrasion,
and that's what I find.
This is an extremely
slick handle.
There's not really much
on this handle
keeping me
from falling back here.
But, all that being said,
you got
a nice-looking knife here,
so well done.
Scott, how you feeling?
-A little nervous.
-[laughs] Understandable.
[rock music playing]
Well, Scott, as you can see,
you're all in one piece.
Um, this one took the slightest
of roll right here
where I can feel it
underneath my finger.
There's some cosmetic issues
going on here.
Your spine jumps down,
and then, handle jumps up.
And there's some gapping
in between the guard
and the blade.
But, uh, your blade
held up well.
-Nice job.
-Thank you.
-Jarrett, you're up. You ready?
-Sure.
-All right. You sound excited.
-Yeah. [laughs]
[rock music playing]
[exhales]
Well, Jarrett, your, uh,
your blade held up really well.
Your edge, where I was hitting,
it's no longer
as sharp as it was.
It's still got an edge in spots
but there's a lot
of glinting along there.
I really like the profile
you got going on here.
This reminds me
of old Celtic iron knives
and fun stuff like that.
I like the proportions
of your handle.
Put my hand in there,
everything is comfortable.
All in all, it's still straight,
still good.
-So, well done.
-Thank you.
[Doug] All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness test.
The leather bag slice.
Now, this is all about
how sharp your blades are
and how well
they cut these bags.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Okay.
[rock music playing]
All right, Colton,
let's talk about your edge here.
On the first two cuts,
you can see right here,
it's not as sharp
from the dulling
from cutting on the stone.
But the edge over here
is razor sharp
and that part
did cut into this bag.
So, your blade, it will cut.
All right, Scott.
Your turn. Ready, sir?
-Yes, sir.
-Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
All right, Scott. Some dulling
from hitting the stone.
But there is some edge over here
that does allow for a cut
on the bottom right there.
-So, it will cut.
-Thank you.
All right, Jarrett, your turn.
You ready?
-Go for it.
-All right.
[dramatic music playing]
All right, Jarrett.
The grind that you have
over here
that was affected by the stone,
it's not as sharp
to cut through these bags.
It will not cut.
Jarrett, it's pretty obvious
your blade doesn't
make the cut, literally.
-[chuckles]
-For that reason,
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands
and then please exit the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
[Jarrett] I think if I had
a little more time
with not dealing with that crack
that came in there,
would've had a little more time
to get that edge nice and sharp
and cut the bag.
I had a blast competing
and everybody was super great,
so I had a fun time.
It was cool
just for the experience.